so the next presentation is by philip
rudiger and he is going to speak about
build polish data driven application
directly from your pandas or excited
pipelines
and if i'm not right philip you're
associated with anaconda right
that's right yeah
yeah
all right hopefully you'll be able to
see my screen
yeah i can and if you could just start
with a short bio yourself that would be
wonderful okay yeah perfect so yeah my
name is philip rudiger i'm based in
berlin germany i work for anaconda here
and i'm a senior software engineer
primarily working on kind of open source
software i develop various open source
tools which you'll see in the course of
this presentation
and yeah i'm very excited to share this
talk with you
[Music]
all right so i'll just uh jump straight
in um yeah i'll be talking to you today
about building polished data driven
applications directly from your pandas
or xray pipelines
so
to start off with what do i mean by a
pipeline
so let's take a very simple sentence as
an example a person drives to the store
to buy food then he drives home prepares
cooks serves and eats the food before
cleaning the dishes
and so in python you might want to write
this as a series of methods operating on
some object so you might have a person
that kind of performs various actions
such as driving to the store buying food
driving home preparing food cooking food
serving food eating food and then
cleaning the dishes right and so in
python we call this method chaining and
that's really what i mean by building
pipelines
so let's jump straight in and look at a
particular data pipeline so actually
operating on some data set right
so here we're looking at the satellite
seattle bike data set
which is here loaded as a data frame
i have skipped the loading step
and so we now might want to perform a
range of operations right so this is
actually a pretty large data set if we
look at the length of this data set
um this is actually pretty long and so
we might might want to resample it
on a daily basis
so we're resampling it take the sum and
then we want to smooth it a little bit
because it's quite noisy data and it
might jump around so we provide a
rolling window right provide
perform the sum on that and then we
might want to plot it and so here we're
using a tv plot to plot it which gives
us this nice interactive plot and we'll
talk about that in a little bit but
really what we're focusing on here is
this pipeline window for operations and
so
both pandas and x-rays we'll see later
provide this ability to chain various
operations in a row
to apply some pipeline but
at the same time kind of we've kind of
picked very relatively arbitrary um to
make relatively arbitrary decisions here
right so daily resampling we actually
have this data on on a kind of a minute
spaces or even even at a final
resolution so daily is kind of an
arbitrary decision uh this particular
value for the rolling mean or rolling
sum is a very arbitrary value more
smoothing maybe you want less smoothing
and so on and so every time we want to
change any of these things we have to go
back in edit that and kind of find the
actual
um
the particular values that we want or
that's appropriate for the effects that
we're trying to find
uh the the kind of
particular transformations we want to do
perform on our data and that process can
take a while right it's it's kind of
going back and forth and so that's what
i'm talking about when i talk about
exploratory workflows and if data is
messy you have to iterate on it you have
to
really to make discoveries in your data
you have to be able to iterate on it
fast and so faster duration cycles are
what makes discovery possible and what
has made particular notebooks so very
popular right they let you kind of
do this kind of process of going back
and forth between editing the code
viewing the output um and so that's why
notebooks are powerful but even a small
amount of coding
the bit i was just talking about kind of
uh editing these particular variables
here even that kind of interrupts this
this past iteration cycle right and so
if we're trying to find the particular
rolling window that's most accurate uh
kind of going back and forth and
incrementing the value or decrementing
value it takes some time and it's kind
of interrupting and it's it's not really
what we want
and so that's why
kind of why are we introducing this new
concept of dot interactive which i'll
kind of explain in a bit more detail in
a minute
um the original um
inspiration for it came from tom
nicholas in this issue on x-ray and so
we wanted to dive into the issue but if
you want to kind of dig into that and
see the discussion there it's quite
interesting
um but i'll just read the kind of
description of the problem out that tom
nikko's provided there so for most users
who are exploring their data will be
common to find themselves re-running the
same cells repeatedly but with slightly
different values
so why not allow them to add widgets
directly to their pipelines
but importantly we also need to make
sure that
we don't require users to kind of learn
new apis they should just be able to use
their existing knowledge of kind of the
pandas api the x-ray api to just drop in
widgets and get an interactive version
of their existing data pipeline
right and so
what is dot interactive well right now
it's a monkey patch accessor on which
supports the common data apis whether
that's pando's data frames dash data
frames uh rapids qdf data frames or
x-ray objects
that are shipped with the hp plot
library
so we'll take as i promised i'll we'll
dig into what the hp plot library is in
a minute um but that interactive allows
us to change these chain these
interactive pipeline methods and replays
when any of the inputs
any of the widgets that we feed into
this pipeline change
it also supports dunder methods which
allows us to do mathematical operations
so if you're not familiar with dunder
methods it's basically the things that
allow objects to
implement things like mathematical
operations plus minus multiplication and
a bunch of other stuff right and then it
also mirrors the api of the wrapped
objects and so let's take an example
here so let's actually stick get it
started with an example so the way we
install the data interactive api on our
pandas objects
um is by importing hvp.pandas
there's also a method you can import to
a function you can import to enable this
explicitly
but this import is the simplest way to
get started
and once we do that we have this
interactive accessor on our objects
which turns our regular data frame into
an interactive object and so here we now
have a handle on this interactive object
uh we can now perform all the regular
operations that you might want to
perform on a pen's data frame except it
now supports widgets and so if i for
example create a panel widget a date
range slider widget i can now kind of
filter the index by the start value of
this date range the
end value of the state range and then
basically show us the first three rows
and so now when i drag this slider here
we kind of we can see the output below
update in response to the dragging of
the widget
so
in this way we kind of built a very very
simple interactive pipeline right it's
basically just two steps
filter and then call dot head so we can
see the first three rows very simple um
but it kind of gets the point across
right so how does that work and so if
you
don't care tune out for just a second
i'll just briefly talk about how this
actually works right
so when the interactive is instantiated
it wraps the current the starting object
so here in this particular case right
when we call this we're wrapping this
seattle bike's data frame uh it queries
that for its methods and dynamically
mirrors its apis so internally that's
just
calling get out your set editor and
those are mirrored
those are basically intercepted and so
whenever you call any method it kind of
checks does that method actually exist
on the underlying object and that
intercepts that it also um
when you make any method call or kind of
do the slicing semantics it intercepts
any widgets or param.parameter objects
you're passing in and
wraps those to ensure that those are
interactive inputs to our pipeline
it also implements various dunder
methods so we can talk do the
mathematical operations
and then when we access any method it
temporarily stores that method accessor
so that we can resolve it when it's
called and finally
when the output is
displayed
it's rendered using the panel library or
hollowvs potentially
and whenever any of the uh widgets or
inputs change the the output is updated
so that's helpful
um so before we dive into any deeper
into
how this works and what you can do with
it uh let's just briefly discuss what is
hb part what is panel right not
everyone's familiar with those so hp
plot is a library i originally wrote um
to kind of mirror the dot plot api um
which is present on pandas objects on
xray objects
which provides you kind of static
mapping output
and provides but provides a really
really convenient entry point to kind of
do exploratory visualization of your
data
and so it also supports geopandas desks
data frames rapids data frames and a few
other libraries
it then renders the outputs to all of
these objects which in turn uh give you
a interactive bokeh plot that you can
kind of zoom in on explore
which is different from the regular
maple leaf output you're used to from
pandas
um and so this dot new dot interactive
api which also lives in hp plot now
extends this these interactive processes
that we've kind of added for
visualization to data exploration data
manipulation
and makes those interactive for you too
so all that is also built on top of
panel if you're not familiar with panel
it's basically a dashboarding library
kind of a very high level dashboarding
library which lets you build
applications either in jupiter and kind
of prototype them in jupiter and then
once you deploy them on a bokeh server
and so it supports rendering a wide
range of widgets various
all different plotting libraries that
you might think of in
the pi data ecosystem are supported and
this way we can kind of take the output
and update it whenever anything changes
um so that's very helpful
um so that's the two libraries this is
built on now let's actually look at a
data pipeline where uh we're applying
some of these these concepts that we've
talked about right and so previously we
kind of talked about we have this
seattle bike data set we've made it
interactive and now we can call various
methods on it and to build this
interactive pipeline
so instead of kind of providing just
the day daily resampling we now provide
a widget which allows us to switch
between daily weekly and monthly
resampling uh instead of providing a
fixed rolling window
we provide a widget that allows us to
kind of have a slider to change those
values right and so now uh just by kind
of replacing
this original data frame and uh
replacing the fixed arguments with
widgets we've now built this interactive
little app
that let's a switch between uh daily
weekly monthly resampling allows us to
adjust the rolling window and so here we
can kind of smooth it until we have the
particular
plot that we want or gain the inside
that we want right so you can see it's
kind of we've got
in winter
bike trips kind of drop and somewhere
they pick up and so uh this is something
well we can also see in the daily
version but in the monthly version we
might not see it and so here we can gain
the insights that we want
just by kind of fiddling with widgets
instead of kind of manually editing
the values in here
so i also promised you this would also
support mathematical expressions
so again we've kind of resampled our
data this time we
just fixed the daily resampling
um but then we provide the window as an
interactive input
we've assigned that to a variable
which then allows us to kind of take the
resampled version the interactive
resampled version and subtract the mean
of that from itself which basically
gives us the difference
from the mean so we can see here how
things drop below the the average um
kind of the number by trip drops below
the average in uh assuming this is
winter and then pick up again
so here
um in this way it kind of we can perform
any operations that we want
you'll also notice here that we've used
hp plot again to plot it which means we
can a we can get hover information we
can zoom the pan around right
we've also provided rasterization here
which means that if we were to do this
on a ah i always forget what the now
this is monthly i think if we did this
on a uh
oh if anyone can remind me what the if
we had a second by second resampling uh
this might take a little minute actually
so that was probably not the best idea
um
but
using this rasterize we can even
get a visualized data sets this large
so but that was a particularly terrible
idea of mine and so for now i'm going to
have to stop the kernel
there and then restart the presentation
um so sorry about that
um
don't resample such a large data set on
a secondly basis is basically
the idea there um okay so we've seen
that we can perform kind of method
chaining we can perform mathematical
operations
um but we can also kind of provide our
own
methods in this data processing pipeline
such that we can pipe things into other
functions other objects and so here
we've built this little interactive
applet where we now take a different
data set uh the penguins datasets if
you're not familiar it's just a
collection of penguins
um
in the antarctic
which with various measurements about
them and so again we're kind of
declaring two widgets a to filter by the
species
secondly to filter by the sex and then
we can again use the regular panda
semantics to a do the filtering and then
uh we can pipe that into any object that
we want any function that we want
so here we're piping it into this
tabular widget tabulator is a very
powerful kind of table
uh widgets that exists in panel
which has things like pagination so that
if we had if this was 10 000 rows or a
million rows this would still work it's
just fetching particularly the rows that
we want and now if i kind of switch
between the different species you can
see the table below also updates and so
yeah
and if i switch species did the sex
you can see the table updates and you
can see here we can kind of go to the
last flip through the pages so that's
quite powerful um this this pipe method
which exists on kindness data frames
kind of lets you do arbitrary transforms
using the function and in the context of
uh hvplot.interactive
this is super this is a superpower
because it lets us pipe things into
any object that we want and render it
render our data in various ways
okay so another very important concept
are terminating methods so a pipeline
right pipes keeps piping data the more
methods you add it keeps piping the data
through like every time it returns a new
object you're chaining things
but at some point you might want to kind
of get the actual object that you're
rendering back you might want to
terminate this pipeline into an object
that you can display or work with in
other ways and so that's what the
terminating methods are for there's four
of them
one basically is the hollowviews method
that just returns a holiday's object
this only works if the term with the
object that we're uh terminating on is a
hollow vision object and so in the case
of using hp plot you would get our
hollow views object back and that's when
you need to use this it's just
this kind of
does an efficient update of the plots
that panel kind of your data could
return anything it can be data frame
itself it could be
anything we can pipe into a panel object
panel will render and update as the
widgets change
then we can also get back the widgets
themselves right we want to lay out the
widgets separately from the actual
output put them in a different place in
our little application and we'll see
that in a minute and so in this way we
can kind of get it layouts and
we can also get a layout of both the
widgets and the panel in one and so it's
kind of a helper around getting a column
of these two objects
okay so those are the terminator methods
so far we've um
focused entirely on pando's data frames
but the title here promised that this
would also work
for x-ray data sets and so here we're
going to work with a very simple this is
the
in the
x-ray docs you'll find this this
particular data set quite frequently
it's air temperatures
over the us
over time so this is basically if you're
not familiar with xray xray is basically
a pandas for n-dimensional data so here
you can think of this as a 3d cube of
air temperatures over as a grid over the
us over time right so you've got images
which are stacked over time and so
you've got this
3d stack and so
the nice thing here is um
this also supports interactive and so we
can do
basically a integer selection we have an
integer slider starting at zero ending
at ten and now we can slide over uh
each slice in this object so we're
stepping through time here uh here this
little wrapper is the representation
that xray provides for this this
particular output
and
so as we're going through time here you
can imagine we're kind of crossing
through time um
but more interestingly we can kind of
actually use the hp plot api to plot
this as well and so here um
you see the same data set now again
explorable through time
except we're now using the cell method
which is basically selection by actual
variable value and so here we're
actually getting the output here is no
longer the integer but the particular
time that we're slicing on right
and so
interactive is quite smart here it
actually knows what the cell method is
it kind of can infer that if you give it
a discrete slider that it should create
an instance of this discrete slider and
populate it with all the times
so that we can cross through time
we're also again making use of the
mathematical mathematical expression
operations so that we subtract the mean
air temperature over this entire time
period so we can kind of see the
diversions from the mean and then
finally we're also providing another
widget to kind of select between
different types of plots so here by
default we're plotting the image
plugging this as an image we can also
switch to plotting it as a contour
or a filled contour and all of this
still allows us to switch to kind of
uh drag the slider to go through time
so that's pretty neat again works just
in the same way as pandas and in fact um
one other nice thing is
that um since we're just mirroring the
api right all the
dock strings still exist so if you're
doing kind of if you're working in
uh by python or in a notebook we can
still get back the dock string even on
this interactive object right uh so
that's that's really nice
um the other
nice thing is of course we've kind of
focused on hp plot output because it's
cool and it gives us these interactive
plots but the regular dot plot api both
for pandas and um x array still work so
here we're again doing this time slider
thing but this time we're just using the
regular.plot api to plot
this using map called
so that works too
which is also pretty neat
um we're also not stuck with the
particular type we started with right so
we might there's actually a way to go
from an x-ray object to a data frame
so we can kind of build a pipeline where
we select
on the x-ray object by latitude and then
we group it over time and plot the mean
temperature at that latitude over time
also by method chaining here so we're
chaining uh going from an x-ray object
to a pandas object uh just changing this
operation and now we can kind of select
the latitude we want to look at and see
how that changes the air temperature
so really it's very very flexible
[Music]
and we can do almost anything in this
way
another thing that i've kind of focused
on is panel this is all built on panel
so panel is a natural kind of widget
library that you can use
but if you want to use an ipad widget
that support works too you can just
drop in any ipad widgets object
in place of the panel object and that'll
work the same so here we've got a player
widget
from ipad widgets which we dropped in
and we get our little player
um okay so i kind of let me just check
the time
okay i do want to leave some time for
questions just um but what i did promise
you is that we're not just building
pipelines where we can actually build an
actual application and a polished
application like that from using this
right
and so what we're going to do here is
we're again going to start with a
different data set in this particular
case we kind of we're going to go
through the entire process of building
an application here
so
i just drag this off screen a little bit
um
so
what we're starting with here is this
earthquake citizen this is the
earthquakes earthquakes across the
entire globe uh over i think a decade
i'm not quite sure um we again start
with this data set this which is again a
data frame we make it interactive we add
some widgets
and then we again use regular pandas api
to do the filtering kind of to allow us
to filter these earthquakes by magnitude
this is the minimum magnitude
we again use a date range slider to
filter it by time and then we look at
what that looks like right we again have
this little uh interactive thing just to
view them
just to view the table and preview the
table
and now we're going to kind of create um
various filters uh various plots of this
so let me just go back so that we can
actually see the plot
um
so there's something odd about this
uh let me re-execute
[Music]
sorry about this uh so we're just going
to re-execute this
and then go back here i think it and we
execute this as well and now we can
actually see uh all of these uh
earthquakes across the world
um if i could actually go back then yes
we can see them all sorry about that and
so now we can zoom in and actually look
at this is i mean several thousand
earthquakes right across the entire
globe
um
and we can see all of them
and
using the data shader library we can
visualize and make sure this is still
interactive
so we've declared this geoplot we're
going to add to our little dashboard
we're going to create some other plots
we're going to add to the dashboard here
are some histograms we're going to add
um
another thing we might want to add is a
little
table
again this is
sorry about this
uh veriz is kind of cutting things off
so i have to go back and forth a little
bit uh but here again we're going to
create a table using the tabulator
library to kind of view the the
particular earthquakes that we've
sub-selected right and so again
this allows us to filter the whole thing
um and so we're just creating various
components to add to our little
dashboard right and all of this all of
these components are created using
the
interactive api
we finally lay this whole thing out
together
and here we're going to put the plots in
a separate tab from the table and so
this is what a panel will let you do
kind of it provides various layouts that
lets us lay things out in different ways
using either columns or tabs
again this is a little bit cut off but
in the final polished dashboard we'll
see that this actually looks pretty nice
um and so just to summarize what we've
just done is we've kind of taken making
made our earthquake data sets
interactive
we've filtered it in some ways we've
created various plots from it such as
the geographic plot histograms
we've created a little table from that
we've put that into a set of tabs and
now we're going to add all of that to
our little polished dashboard template
so panel
if you don't know it provides various
templates that you can just drop your
components into and the api for that is
very simple so all we're going to do
here is
append our widgets to the sidebar append
our tabs
to
the main area and then we're going to
preview this thing
just let me show before we do that let
me just make sure that i re-executed
this so that it all just works
and now
this shell method will let us preview
this if we actually deploy it we could
kind of put this in a script or in a
notebook and make that
work nicely as well
and so here
just by adding this interactive pipeline
that we've built
to a dashboard
to this template we can create this
really nice polished dashboard we can
kind of change our filters uh we can
adjust the filters
the other is nice thing we added to this
dashboard and if you've watched very
closely i added this thing called linked
selections
which i actually talked about at pi data
global last year
which kind of lets us filter
by region so let's take this this region
here over japan
and filter by that
which allows us kind of see
here all the other plots will update in
response to the selection now because i
used link selections uh you
may be able to see in the background
very faintly the full data set and then
the subset of kind of data points that
fall into that correspond to the region
i selected i can further sub select
right just select magnitudes
from five and higher or seven higher or
i could also subselect the depth
um and then even the table will update
correspondingly right so we primarily
have uh earthquakes in japan and russia
selected now
so hopefully what you can take away from
this is uh just in a few lines of code
or using apis that you already know you
can build an interactive pipeline
and then drop the resulting plots the
resulting analyses into a little panel
template and get a really nice and
polished application and i think this is
less than 60 lines of code total i think
it's probably more like 40 actually
this also has a nice feature you can
kind of
i don't think it works in this
particular case
but you should also be able to toggle
between dark and light themes
okay
so let me just go back to our little
presentation here
and hopefully we still have some time
for
questions
hopefully we can go to the last slide
all we need i think i just crashed my
browser and so we're going to finish it
here the last slide just thanks all of
you for joining here
and
maybe i can restart that
thanks for joining everyone you can find
more information about this at
holovis.org so this has a whole tutorial
explaining all of this if you have any
questions you can visit us at
discourse.holobiz.org
and really yeah i'm looking forward to
your questions at this point
thanks very much everyone
yeah thank you philip this was a
wonderful presentation and i really like
the demos
uh so we have do we do have questions
for you uh the first question is like
what is a software using for to present
i think this is rise right this is rice
that's right yes yeah i've been using it
for years
and it's yeah
damon damien obia um developed it
originally um it's really great it's
really just a wrapper around notebooks
and so maybe if i
drop back out of here if you install the
extension for a classic notebook you get
a little button here um that lets you
kind of
present and it also lets you kind of
annotate with for each cell whether that
should be a slide or fragment okay
hopefully that covers that yeah uh so
people are really keen on seeing our
slides so would you please share these
and share the notebook in the uh slack
channel
in the slack channel um i will have to
upload it um i haven't i've
only just put the final tweaks on it um
so if you go to my github i'm going to
create a new repo i'll call it pi data
oh maybe we can just do that together
now
i'll create a new repo called
pi data global 2021 and i'll put it in
there um i do have another comment
comment which go which is this is great
this is great presentation the total
opposite of death by powerpoint
yeah the other another question is by
andrea uh
does it does it also work in a streamlit
app
that's a very good question i
i haven't tried um so in theory at least
it will render i don't know if the
widgets the widgets probably won't
respond unfortunately
um
so
you can use panel instead which kind of
competes we've heard a little bit i
think there was a discussion yesterday
which i unfortunately have to miss about
the drawbacks of panel versus
streamlight but i uh
i'll hopefully start a conversation with
the stream with devs so we can kind of
hopefully make this work somehow
okay uh the other question is how is
this deployed to users
okay so if you uh that's a very good
question so if you go to panel and the
user guide it has a whole section on
kind of uh
deployment uh deploying and export uh
particularly server deployments uh
really there is a command line uh
command line arguments or command line
tool where you can just do a panel serve
and point it to the dashboard and that
will start a server which you can deploy
on any of your favorite cloud providers
such as like well aws google cloud or
whatever you want
so here the shell method really just
just to preview
if you instead put servable here
and save that i could now run on the
command line panel serve
pi data
2021 ipy and b and that would start a
server which you can deploy on any of
your favorite cloud servers right
yeah that seems like an easy way and you
know very accessible
yeah uh so that we are almost at the
time so uh
i would just close this presentation and
thank you very much for joining us today
and you know giving this beautiful
presentation thanks so very much for
moderating and yeah i'll post the this
repo here uh there once i've uploaded
the slides as well sure thank you very
much great thanks everyone